una vez sofocado el motín armado de los
banner del mes pasado el crimen afronta
ahora la tarea de ver qué hace con este
grupo de mercenarios fundado por
jeffganish el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin ha dicho que los Wagner
oficialmente no existen y es cierto
porque el parlamento ruso jamás emitió
una ley que regularse los grupos de
mercenarios Aunque sí que es cierto que
el gobierno ruso durante años como el
propio Putin ha admitido los ha estado
financiando el portavoz del crimen
Dimitri prescott ha explicado hoy que
tal vez sí es hora de que el parlamento
ruso de algún tipo de Rango legal a
estos grupos de mercenarios o por lo
menos que lo tenga en cuenta en alguno
de sus debates el presidente ruso está
interesado sobre todo en que estos
mercenarios sigan luchando en un formato
o en otro bajo un paraguas legal o bajo
otro tipo de estructura en el frente de
Ucrania y por eso
ha ofrecido a los integrantes de Wagner
que sigan luchando en el frente de
Ucrania pero integrados en el ejército
ruso una idea que ya estuvo sobre la
mesa pero que siempre ha chocado con las
antipatías que despierta la actual
cúpula militar de Rusia en algunos
sectores de Los mercenarios de Wagner